We all have apprehensions when it
comes to money.
So I thought, why not use technology
to help with that?
Money Forward lets you manage
your financial information
from bank accounts to credit cards,
bonds, and loyalty points
all from one app.
With just a glance at your smartphone,
you can check everything instantly
your income, your outgoings,
your current balance, and so on.
All of which are updated in real time.
We inquired about Google's Material
Design as soon as it was announced
and it's been really beneficial
to us.
Within the first month, we experienced
a 30% increase in total users
a 7% increase in user retention
and a 4% decrease in bounce rate.
Using the UI templates on offer
we were able to create a great
UI that works for our product.
We've found that tablet users are
1.5 times more likely to pay for
in-app purchases than smartphone users.
While users who use both
smartphones and tablets
are around three times as likely.
Before using Material Design
we had to set aside a lot of time
whenever there was an OS update.
But now, the Android Support Library
guarantees that even after an OS update
the app will behave the same.
It's a real time saver.
CoordinatorLayout is a great
example of how it has helped.
There was one case where we'd
developed a feature
to automatically hide the header
when scrolling down a page.
But this stopped working after
an OS upgrade.
Fortunately, this kind of function is
now covered by the Support Library.
Our app will soon support Android Wear.
You can now add to your account book
using voice recognition.
We're also thinking of adding
a feature to notify users
about their incoming debits.
For example, "Payment due on Monday."
or, "Your balance is insufficient."
Given that our service handles
sensitive customer information
we are very mindful of security.
This means operating strict security
measures at every step
from handling device data
to encrypting transmissions.
Google gives us the perfect platform
to explore new technology and
create great applications
that we hope will have a positive
impact on many people's lives.